a draw is almost inevitable now his
winning chances have gone they were
temporary earlier we saw the black king
trapped but as soon as the black king
escaped no more winning chances it's
level material no way forward now and uh
okay dude they're giving a check
the white king will step forward
all that black needs to do is eliminate
the white pawns or trade a set of rocks
just black's doing everything right i
think just trying to exchange pieces
exchange pawns remove everything try to
get to king versus king which we saw
make the draw win the match and uh um
eric yeah he's uh
i mean it was very hard to see a win
there none of us saw the win that eric
had and somehow dude had just dodged
dodged the checkmate and when things
don't go your way they just don't go
your way and i feel that's something
that you know it's just not gone eric's
way this this tournament we're down to
two seconds
oh did trades with two seconds left
moved his king across
but yeah he's actually played really
well this one game eric but
unfortunately just it's so hard to beat
the top players in the world you have to
beat them over and over and over again